so you feel like this is kind of like
your level up my level up 100 bigger
beats you know I mean um great features
musically sound good my Cadence
everything sounds well I feel good about
it do you have the name of the album yet
um yeah bless to the max you the first
one I know that though I ain't say this
yet so the name of my album is called
bless to the max that's dope I like that
why that title man cause I'm blessed you
know I got um a bullet in my head you
know I'm able to survive I'm still here
um
I've been through a lot this year so we
blessed it I didn't know you got when
did you get shot
um 2011. [ __ ] yeah how old were you
you're like a kid I want to say like 17
[ __ ] 17. yep so what what happened man
um I want to say it was like the wrong
place wrong time you know sometimes it's
all you know yeah like different
energies colada you know it was it was
just the wrong place at the wrong time
so you got shot in the head and I had
well didn't go to the hospital for every
time I tell a story people think I'm
crazy she got shot in the head and
didn't go to the hospital then because I
didn't know I didn't know I was shot I
thought I got Grace So a couple years
after
um I figured out I had a bullet in my
head so I lived like three years with
the bullet in my head before I found out
so that's to the max bro for sure how
did you find out that the bullet was in
there so like I I was still on school I
was having these like sinus problems and
[ __ ] my head was killing me yeah so I
went to go get the sinus checked out you
know they give you the MRI right and
they told me like you got like a piece
of metal in your head maybe that's where
it's coming from but yeah and I didn't
fix it no no no no no no because it was
the sinus issue this wasn't bothering me
my bullet wasn't bothering me it was the
sinus issue so when I got the meds for
the sinus the pain went away but I still
got the bullet in my head that's how I
discovered it yeah it's still here oh
man it can't go nowhere it don't make
sense to take it out right yeah because
it'll stop [ __ ] things up
okay bro Blaster than Max how did your
parents like feel when they found out
that there was a like I'm sure they knew
about the incident but like I mean they
thought it was Grace so I went I went
home to my stepmom I put some like
bacitration
you know what I mean little ointment on
it and I went on about life like we
nobody knew when we found out it was
like oh that's crazy yeah well yeah yeah
I feel like uh if you were
I feel like a lot of rappers would just
be talking about that all the time yeah
yeah I mean yeah for me there's not
nothing to glorify it is it is I'm
blessed I think of course every day but
being shot in I ain't trying to use that
as you know I mean I just think back to
50 and we all knew he got shot nine
times we did we did have you I mean I
know pop smoke did a many-man remix but
have you thought about like kind of I
mean you kind of have a pretty crazy I
think little little TJ just did many men
too all right oh he did a freestyle yeah
yeah yeah okay going to Don Q or whoever
I don't know I think yeah yeah I think
they was dissing each other on that yeah
and both I mean Don Q's can really rap
the TJ's hard too yeah shout out to them
guys man yeah